spent two years of your life dedicated
this book we blew the launch out of the
water so what now
today we're going to be going to four
different podcasts to talk about what's
next for the brand and Beyond thank you
oh it's your last one I'm not gonna do
that too no no I will never take a man's
last piece of gum no it's crude and
unusual thank you hello the last piece
is always a holy piece I would have done
this with him and like split it
late in the stop
yeah let's rock your wedding ring is
rubber yeah the other ring it was like
it would get a little tight while I was
sleeping and I would end up taking it
off while I'm asleep and I'd be like
where is it Mark you are ridiculously
good at
manuals for how to make money but if
people don't know how to think and
they've got a life structure that
doesn't make any sense and they're
wasting time on the social media or even
just a friend group that is going
nowhere fast what advice do you have for
them to get back one of my favorite
quotes from BF Skinner who's a behavior
psychologist from way back in the day
was you can lead a horse to water but
you can't make a drink he said well if
you bleed it out enough and you starve
it and you leave it in the sun and you
put the water right in front of its
mouth he said I can invaritably
guarantee that I can make a drink
and so if you were to think about
yourself as that horse then it's like
okay well what is the equivalent of the
the bloodletting the dehydration the
starving that you can put yourself into
get the behavior you want so starving
has a negative connotation but we can
also starve out
the negative things in your life like
you can starve the alcohol you can
starve the friends and I think the
easiest way to do that is to get out of
the environment you're in I think this
was in atomic habits in Vietnam
like I think it was like 10 of troops or
something we're taking heroin when they
were there in the 70s and they thought
there's going to be this massive problem
when they came back to the States but
when they came back to the States almost
no one continued the heroin habit and so
going from Vietnam where you're doing
heroin to the U.S where you're not doing
taking heroin had a 90 success rate
whereas the inverse is true of recovery
centers in the United States today
people go there and 90 of them relapse
when they go back home and so the
difference is that people were doing
heroin in a different environment and
then they changed their environment and
then they never went back to the
environment that they did heroin in to
be fair I think the reason a lot of
people kind of like some of the content
that I put out from a money-making
perspective is how can I operationalize
this word right so like patience for
example is when people throw out a lot
but for me defining patience was helpful
which is figuring out what to do in the
meantime
like that's patience
like you're like I'm not patient it's
like no you just need to figure out what
to do in the meantime I think these are
like mental models around using emotions
to fuel the behaviors that you want so
me defining amorphous terms like
confidence winning respect loyalty
sadness anxiety have come from my own
desire to understand the words and
reading the dictionary definitions and
feeling like they don't provide much and
they can't help me what is love and you
know people like it's a feeling that
that doesn't help me how do I
operationalize this word love for me how
much are you willing to sacrifice to
maintain a relationship
that is how you can measure love you
could use an example of like man that
guy works on that piece of crap car all
the time he must really love it right
like he's willing to sacrifice a lot to
maintain that thing to the same degree
many people would sacrifice everything
for their kids now there's plenty of
times where they don't like their kids
but they'd be willing to die for their
children you might be willing to die for
your country and so when I Define these
terms it has been out of my own
self-interest to learn how to navigate
life better you just did a book launch
it was Unreal I mean really like blew
people's minds set a standard or what
did you demonstrate in the way that you
did that that other people don't
understand with each book I wanted to
demonstrate the concept of the book with
the book itself since the concept of the
book was to advertise and to get lots of
leads then I thought it would be
appropriate to
advertise and get lots of leads and I
used every method in the book I ran ads
for it even though I didn't need to run
ads we still got 137 000 people from ads
we had Affiliates we had 104 000 people
there from Affiliates we had 27 000
Affiliates promote the book we had
customer referrals people sent their
friends there so I had an incentive that
if you just get 10 people to come you'll
get two bonus chapters that aren't
released with the book and so you know
the next book I'll try and continue that
meta theme of
I have Concepts in this book and I will
show you that they work because I will
use them to Market and promote the book
tell me on a nose trip it says b one of
zero what does that mean so one of zero
is a brand that I am really passionate
about the concept one of zero actually
came from my media team you know we talk
about content in general is one of one
content like we try to make content that
only we can make and that's actually one
of my Big Marketing rules is that say
what only you could say show it only you
can show as we were approaching the
event the team learned more and more
about what we were going to be giving
away and how much we're putting into it
and they're like dude this isn't even
one of one this is one of zero and
that statement just clicked and then
everyone latched on to it because it
wasn't about just doing what only we
could do it was doing what no one else
would do if you look at one of zero one
divided by zero from a mathematical
perspective it's undefined and I think a
lot of that
is stuff that I resonate with which is
doing work that no one else will do is
doing the things that other people will
tell you not to do and
foregoing the shoulds and the must and
the have to's that people around you
tell you to do because they want to
project their life and their expeditions
on yours but you want to live in direct
contrast to that because you want to be
your own person and be Beyond definition
and let your actions be the only thing
to Define you one of one is doing the
things that only you can do but one of
zero is doing things that you're not
even sure you can do yet appreciate you
man
a Chick-fil-A action what is the
Chick-fil-A order I go uh 12 count
grilled nugs four count fry tenders and
then a spicy chicken Deluxe no cheese
with Chick-fil-A sauce and ranch
that's the go-to
if you can only choose between one sauce
out of every restaurant it would be uh
no it'd be um the Persian yogurt sauce
go with the roots yeah I mean it also
has nutritional value It's Yogurt it's
got protein in it right a little fat
it's refreshing what's the sign of a
good podcast interview for you number
one is my uh rapport with the host if
we're comfortable then automatically the
conversation is going to be better the
second thing is how much they know about
me and our stuff if I'm doing like
Recaps it's less interesting if I were
to do a third and fourth thing it is
quality of the follow-on questions
because there are some people who have
like these are 12 questions that I will
ask Alex they ask a question I answer
the question then they say question two
and then they they don't dive deeper
into it which to me makes it almost
makes it seem like they're not listening
because then it's not a conversation
it's really just like 12 short clips the
last one uh is really their ability to
let silence exist I will say that I have
noticed this about the best podcast
hosts is that like they will ask a
question
and then I might answer and they will
just they will just sit at the end of
that and then give me another second or
two and then I might add something to it
that might be the the real nugget or
crystallization of thinking and if you
have a really rushed Cadence in terms of
how the conversation is going it becomes
more difficult to have thoughtful
responses
oh wow
what's up stud how's it going man good
to see you man what have you learned in
the last year the hardest work I've done
has been my redefining winning I think
for me that is like that has been my big
unlock for how much effort I can put in
to make better and keep pushing so I
think one of the hardest things as an
entrepreneur or just an individual is
Shifting how you define winning for
yourself and it's easy to say it and say
of course I'm in the game I'm winning
it's much harder to actually believe
that and so it's easy to make the
Instagram clip but it's hard to live it
and what's been interesting for me is
that I feel like it's unlocked a
different level of work ethic I thought
that the fear of the gun to your head is
still the strongest motivator and it is
in the short term
but if you need to run a marathon then
you need to have something that is going
to sustain for a longer period of time
like punishment is always stronger the
short term reward is always longer in
the long term and so we have to redefine
uh we reward ourselves for the work we
do and so since I don't believe in
Legacy and I don't believe that in 5000
years people are going to remember who I
am I had to
make winning working as hard as I could
on something how do you measure working
as hard as you can tough I think about a
future version of myself who has all the
context in my current situation my
skills uh the information available to
me the resources I have and that man
that feature man knows what perfect work
looks like which is how much effort can
I put into this thing
and not be distracted and continue to
Chisel away at this project it's very
hard because it means there's very few
projects that I can do if I have that
level of work as my new standard and so
if that level of work is the standard
and that is what winning is then I can
only do it for a few things there's just
a lot of things I'm not going to be able
to do which is sad in some ways but I
think a necessary trade-off because like
we have one human life
hair band
no strip
ready I tested a zillion different bags
to get the bag that I have I wear one
pair of shorts and one beater if I want
to conserve space I can do two to one so
I can do two beaters per one pair of
shorts I can wear shorts twice I know
I'm risque I like that I bring no strips
and I usually have one flannel or button
down that I bring with me and I wear the
same shoes that are appropriate in all
venues I can wear in the gym I can wear
them to a restaurant I can wear them on
stage that makes packing take
less than a minute for me and that's how
I like it and so I can pretty much work
until the moment we have to leave and I
just throw my two beaters in and my
shorts and I'm good to go the first time
you put them on you're like this is not
going to make it better if you ever have
breathing problems whenever you've got
like a good line of of air you're like
don't with it you know like just
let it go so you go here to just destroy
all of the good stuff
and then you take your first breath and
you're like
I didn't know the air could be so sweet
the studs what's up man what up Council
we need to do something about
billionaires I am proposing that the
city of Los Angeles banned billionaires
from the beach
what do you think is the biggest mistake
content creators make today not being
them basically getting taken over by the
algorithm and then like talking about
blue trees when they don't actually
with blue trees right but they did it
because they did one blue tree post and
people brought that back right so it had
to
um and so you got a lot of likes and
they're like maybe I'll start making
more stuff on Blue trees but like then
they go down that Alleyway for six
months or a year and then they're like
oh I'm like the blue tree Channel but
like I don't even care about trees like
that's not the stuff I like talking
about and so they can't actually sustain
it because the biggest brands are built
over decades not days or weeks or months
a secret confession the majority of my
news feed almost all of it is uh
Comedians and that's because I like
comedy and I think comedy and philosophy
are probably my two great interests in
terms of things that I consume because
they are the two the two truth tellers
of society it's philosophers and
comedians I love what they do and I also
think like what more philanthropic
line of work can you have than to just
bring joy to people
I think that's really cool and I I have
a lot of admiration for the craft and so
I'd like to do more stuff in that Arena
if the comedic world will happen as of
this morning both 100 million dollar
offers and 100 million dollar leads are
on Amazon charts so top 20 books on all
Amazon we have two of them yeah we beat
Harry Potter
take that JK I'm kidding you're amazing
and I'm a huge fan of your work I'll say
American chicken and rice is like man
that's why you got to go off the sword
gotta go Middle Eastern style some jujit
Kebab if you know you know
[Music]
hello hello how are you bro good man you
need to get back in the gym I know I
cleaned out a little bit the challenge
for you is going to be you continuing to
grow and experience and dig deeper into
not becoming a repetitive like
everybody in the space yeah you know
exactly what I mean because you are the
best right now and you take on that
title it took you a while you were like
a rising dude coming up from like he's
gonna do it he's gonna do it he's gonna
do it now you've done it and by the way
when I talk to other people this is kind
of a consensus it's not like I'm giving
you some compliment no one else has told
you I think you're the best right now
thanks man I say right now because
that's not a title that you need to keep
long term you have to keep arguing and
fighting for it and scratching but
you're the best right now you just spent
two years of your life dedicated to this
book you spent six hours every day
writing it and
so what now
more better
we will do more of what we were doing
before we'll do it better I do have my
project uh you have one of zero that I'm
working on in the background at the same
time I still have my third book and I
think a lot of a lot of people are going
to make a lot of money from it which I'm
very excited about and we'll you know
get more companies in acquisition.com
but uh I have I have two big projects
that I'm working on one is the third
book uh the other is is one of zero and
those are kind of the two big projects
that I have for the next two years